as you get really good at getting things
done what tends to happen is that you
realize that you're getting really good
at getting the unimportant things done
and actually the important things are
being pushed back over the horizon just
as much as ever and i think what's going
on there is just the more you convince
yourself that you can do everything the
less filtering you apply when something
comes onto your radar
oliver bergman welcome to the show
thanks very much for inviting me
what's the unique challenge with time do
we actually have time
it's so weird i mean time is time is
fundamentally i think like unlike any
other
thing uh in a million different ways and
probably also a million different ways
related to physics that i hope you're
not gonna
ask me about but um yeah i mean one of
the things you're i think getting out
there is like yes the very notion that
we even have it to be managing or to be
making good use of or to be making poor
use of the very idea that it's even in
our possession in the first place
seems very flawed when you stop to think
about it because
you don't ever really have uh you don't
have you don't possess next week or the
rest of today you expect it um but you
don't um but you don't possess it in a
way that you can sort of set it aside
for later um
we just get one moment uh
uh one moment after each moment and it's
the same for everybody yeah what do most
people get wrong about time management
then
i think the sort of core uh mistake that
i've certainly spent you know many years
of my life
making and maybe still make to some
extent and that i'm
trying to address
is
it it's this idea that we can ever get
into a position of
mastery and control full control over
time right so so we feel like
what you have to do in this situation of
being overwhelmed by
activities obligations tasks ambitions
is to sort of become capable of
meeting all of these
you know being sort of
optimal optimally productive and capable
of handling anything that's thrown at
you and also to feel kind of secure with
respect to the the future to know that
your plans are gonna come into
fruition and i think that that desire to
be in control of time uh sort of leads
us massively astray because it's not
possible and so in trying to do this
impossible thing we end up actually
spending time
in really sub-optimal ways because we're
really chasing that feeling of
like being in the driver's seat
and then like wanting to win the battle
right and you can't win the battle all
the time in the end time is going to win
that battle yes it's a bit of a was it
king canut or whatever it was that tried
to stop the tide from coming in it's
precisely the same as him so is time
management anxiety a modern phenomenon
i think the way we experience it today
is absolutely a modern phenomenon i mean
you can look at this in different time
scales right on the one hand
if you're going back to
the medieval period i don't think the
average sort of english peasant would
have had any concept of time as a
as a separate thing as a as a thing that
was there to be used or wasted or well
used it was just sort of like there was
this kind of unalienated um
way of being in time it was just the
medium in which life unfolded so to have
any kind of anxiety about time you first
of all
have to you know invent clocks and
disidentify from
time and see it as this thing that is
constantly sort of
like a yardstick that's constantly
you're running alongside or something
like that
and then i think there's a much more
recent
thing which is to do with the sort of
pace of acceleration and economic
competition and all sorts of things just
in the last few decades
where that effort to use
time in the way we think we need to
becomes
sort of unignorably obviously impossible
right i think there's probably a quite a
long period after the industrial
revolution when people are being a bit
stressed by time but this feels doable
like it feels like
you could
render your life or your factory uh you
know
as efficient as it needed to be to stay
on top of everything and i think
just much more recently there's a sense
that that sort of
that possibility is breaking down you
see what i mean
is it not just that we're busier than
people in the old nera were like we've
got more things to do
i don't think it is just that we
definitely feel busier than people did a
few decades ago
um
and
i think that um
there's actually a fairly good it's very
good evidence that we're not busier by
in a sort of objective sense in in the
sense of having more um
having less leisure time we actually
have more leisure time than than a few
decades ago it just doesn't feel
very relaxing and then yeah if you're
talking about this time scale that goes
back to
pre-industrial times or you're including
kind of some indigenous
cultures perhaps even today
um
then it's like well what does busy even
mean right i mean uh their time is full
but this but this situation of feeling
like you have to do more than you can do
which is totally absurd right this is a
logical logical contradiction you can't
have to do more than you can do um i
don't think that arises for people in
those cultures or at those points in
in history so that then it's sort of
like
the question becomes meaningless the
further back you look i suppose that's
the conflict right the conflict is
between
what we feel we should be getting done
and the amount of time in which we have
to get it done
right
and that's the squeeze
yeah that's that's the real
trap when it comes to
what we call busyness you know i write
in the book like busyness per se
i don't know if you're familiar with the
richard scary children's books which uh
which um i am because i've
read many of them to my four-year-old
but you that they're set in a place
called busy town and all the animals in
them are take like human jobs so like
the firefighters are pigs and the
grocers are raccoons and all the stuff
and like the whole deal is they're busy
but that really brings home that busy
can mean something perfectly benign
which is just
that you have a lot of things to do
and
the day is sufficient to contain them
there's no there's no um
tension there that's just like
being busy that's a lovely way to live
um
what we have is overwhelm right what we
have is the sense that we need to be
doing more than
we are gonna have the chance to do and
it's a really weird
predicament because you know there's
this idea in philosophy that
ought implies can that you can't um
you can't meaningfully talk about having
some due to your obligation
uh if it's if it's not possible to
fulfill it um
it's not my obligation it can't be my
moral obligation to save you from a
burning building if the burning building
is 2000 miles away and there's no
possibility of getting there in time in
the same way like it can't be my
obligation to get through more
activities than it is possible for a
human to get through in the course of a
day and yet that mismatch that weight of
that pressure that sense that you know
it is sort of the stakes are high
and that we have to do it and that we
can't do it is a sort of
total recipe for
uh
stress yeah
but the belief is that if i just became
more focused more efficient if i
up regulated my productivity system or
down regulated my sleep that actually
could
get more in
right and of course you can right this
this is not a tirade against the very
idea of efficiency if it's taking you
two hours to like
brew your coffee and uh get washed and
dressed in the morning like they're our
housemates my housemate was taking two
hours to bri but probably about i [ __ ]
you not probably about 30 minutes to
make a coffee during lockdown because
he's a
physio for a professional sports team
who weren't playing and he was just
every day there was fresh sourdough
bread and like two or three pots of
artisan created coffee every day
i've got nothing it's either this or
xbox so
yeah yeah i mean you know if the value
of the value you're pursuing is uh is
really good coffee then maybe it should
take you that long but i mean there's no
harm in making efficiency savings in
life that can be very that can be very
useful but i think the situation that
we're in is
we're in a world of effectively infinite
inputs um
no limit to the number of emails you
could receive or demands that can be
made of you or of you know places you
want to visit on your bucket list and
business ventures you want to launch
it's not all negative but it is all kind
of limitless
and we're limited time is finite in a
life in a day so
yeah the
struggle to optimize to the point where
a finite
uh person can do an infinite amount is
um
is is doomed to failure that's not how
math works right but yeah but it's um
but it also keeps alive this feeling
that maybe next week maybe with the
right system
maybe with just a bit more
self-discipline you can sort of
burst through uh to that to that serene
situation having spent a lot of time
talking to
people like james clear and ali abdal
and you know these sort of real modern
productivity wizards
it
that there always is in the back of my
mind a sense of never being done
never being done with advancing the
productivity system
there's an allen watts quote that says
you can become so preoccupied with
trying to improve your life that you all
together forget to live it
and
you can roll that out
to
talk about the systems themselves so you
can sort of become very matter about
this you can spend so much time working
on your productivity system to enhance
your ability to get more done that you
don't even get around to getting stuff
done let alone yeah you know so there's
there are and i've totally been there as
well i mean like i have you know yeah
absolutely yes the overheads start to
sort of take away from any possibility
of doing anything else yeah and i think
learning
when
when you have optimized sufficiently
deeply when you've down regulated the
sleep and up regulated the the system to
a level where you're happy with it and
this is something
that so many young guys that kind of
follow a similar track to what i did you
know 20 year old guys who start running
a business and really enjoy it and want
to do more and they attach their sense
of success and self-worth to how the
business is performing
you can get into a spiral of working an
awful lot
but
you need to set yourself an upper bound
because you will just erode away
every single second of your life if
you're not careful you can just continue
to chip away and chip away and chip away
at everything and then
you think well what what was the
productivity in service of like what's
the end goal of what i'm trying to
achieve here presumably it's a life
that's fulfilled and satisfied and happy
and comfortable with sufficient
resources but not so many that i can't
spend them that over earnings seems just
as stupid as underearning
yeah absolutely and you know there's
been some amazing work um i'm thinking
right now of a book by
daniel markovitz about how
um
you know your reward for being a winner
in the society that we live in now for
like getting to the great best
universities and getting the best jobs
is this sort of pressure to work with
crushing intensity as he puts it that is
kind of
in that respect
not much
not particularly preferable to
um working with crushing intensity just
to keep a roof over your head i mean
there are there are other upsides for
sure but it's like that it's not like
like
the whole point of being wealthy at any
point in history until fairly recently
was like so you didn't have to work
right so you could like hunt stag and
have banquets or whatever um and now the
reward for climbing up that ladder in
this sort of efficiency dominated
situation is
is just even more
that you that you have to do i think you
know
i guess this is an observation that goes
back to like max weber and probably
before but
what happens is that efficiency becomes
kind of self self-justifying right so it
becomes it becomes the end to which the
system is
uh
tailored rather than heart's law kicks
in very hard yes right rather than a
weight yes exactly rather than a way of
um
of maximizing the
the degree to which you're achieving
some some other goal some other value
and
especially you know the
the
the the in some ways the worst part of
this is that it doesn't actually it sort
of attracts more
input right so this is just this is
parkinson's law this is all sorts of
other observations from all sorts of
uh different domains but like
if all you do is make a system more
efficient
in the service of nothing other than
making it more efficient then all else
being equal it will attract more and
more inputs until it's overwhelmed again
like when they put an extra lane on the
m25 or whatever and more cars come
and it will fill with sort of lower
quality
stuff so
your reward for becoming brilliantly
efficient is to be busier than before
like
on on less meaningful things if that's
if that's what you're pursuing in the
absence of anything else yeah what
should i go with time b then
wow i mean
i've got all sorts of like i can talk
about techniques till the cows come home
but i think that the
i think that the really important thing
is
it is a kind of inner gesture it's a
sort of um
it's a it's a kind of surrender
to to reality and to the limited
situation that we're
that we're in
um and understanding that you can't
control or dominate or master time that
we're just in time we
i think
you know arguably we sort of are a
stretch of time that's how totally we're
just sort of trapped in this situation
and
i think we don't like how that feels so
a lot of what we engage in as
productivity or self-improvement is
actually an attempt to
avoid these uncomfortable emotions but
if you can sort of let them percolate
through you a bit
the actual job of
using time well then becomes kind of
easy because that's just a question of
spending
some of your
whatever amount of discretionary time
you have on things that you know
are the most important things for you to
be doing and i don't like in the book i
don't try to
give a laundry list like these are the
things you ought to be spending a
meaningful life on i think most people
when they get quiet and introspect a bit
don't have a lot of problem answering
that that question the problem is they
expect it to feel comfortable to be
pursuing those things and it probably
isn't going to because it's going to
bring you into contact with
reality and limitation in various ways
that that spending all day scrolling
through twitter
does not
what's the rule with limitation and
finitude here
what's the role of limitation infinitude
well it's just completely defining right
i mean it's just it it it is it
it
it's how things actually are
uh
the fact that you know every choice you
make to do something is a choice to not
do a million other things with that
period of time the fact that you can't
exert very much control or even
influence over the future a little bit
but you certainly can't know that things
are going to go the way you need them to
and so the problem in a way is trying to
is trying to cure this situation it's
not the situation it's the fact that
we spend so much of our time and so much
especially much of our energy and
self-improvement and productivity
trying to
pretend that this is not the way things
are and that we are in more control than
than we really are so i mean
the um there's a quote which i love and
keep coming back to from charlotte jocko
beck the americans and buddhist which is
what makes it unbearable is your
mistaken belief that it can be cured
which i think is like totally brilliant
because it's like it's not that there's
not gonna be difficulties it's not that
there aren't disappointments and losses
involved in
in uh you know being alive and trying to
make something of your life
it's this idea that
we ought to be able to have it not be
that way and we're going to be stressed
and anxious and indignant
all the way until we finally
reach that that situation which we then
never do
sam harris had this quote it doesn't
sound very upbeat though no but i i
think it's correct sadly
we're finite creatures surrounded by
infinite complexity
right they're incapable of infinite
imagination as well i think correct yeah
so not only is the are there an infinite
number of options of what we could do
with our time but we can actually
envision them
and mistakenly we can believe that we
could perhaps maybe do them if we were
able to to get the right productivity
system and the task management and i've
seen that guy on the internet that can
type at 260 words a minute i bet he can
get all of his work done i bet he's able
to run three businesses and continue the
house moving forward but yes sam harris
has this
this quote where he says um
you're never going to not have problems
right what did you just think one day
that you were going to wake up and you
would have completed problems like like
leveling up in a video game and entering
into a map where there's no features
no
the the problems are going to be that
they are a feature not a bug of life
yeah
yeah
right and they're just generated by
they're just generated by the situation
that we're in right i mean
what's the definition of a problem it's
that
in the most basic sense i suppose it's
that um
you know
that
that something is not
the way you wish it to be and it's there
for you to try to turn it into something
you do wish it to be
well that's always going to be true and
solving one problem is going to
cause another so um yeah i think it's i
think that's a lot of the tenor of a lot
of the popular and sort of definitely
sort of more aimed at men
male readers
self-help of the last
few
years i'm thinking of the stuff sam
rights but obviously also jordan
peterson is the obvious
example in this mix and really i think a
lot of it all goes back down to that
book the road less traveled which is
years old and a lot and a lot it's not
so um
it's not so heavy on the sort of
masculinity
stuff but it basically comes to the same
message and the beginning paragraph is
something like
uh
life is difficult
um this is one of those problems that
this is one of the great problems which
means that once it's accepted it's no
longer a problem or something like that
and it's like
that's the point yeah i
i couldn't have said it better even than
the garbled version that i just gave you
what's the efficiency trap then is that
just becoming more efficient and more
productive productive
in an effort to then fill up the
remaining time with more stuff to be
done as opposed to using that time to
spend on things that a leisure
yeah i mean i just use that phrase
there's sort of two aspects to this one
is as we've discussed right that um
becoming more efficient in the absence
of
any other value will just increase your
workload and your business and uh and
work will
rush in to fill the
extra capacity
you're creating
through various different means you know
and the obvious one is email right i
mean if you're really really good at
responding to email you're going to get
more email because
you're going to get replies and then you
have to reply to those and
blah blah blah there's also this
qualitative aspect which i sometimes
sometimes call the importance trap i
think i think i need to be more rigorous
in the proprietary names i'm giving my
concepts
um it's holding me back um but which is
this sort of stems from this observation
in my own life but i've many many people
have have sort of resonated with it
since that like
as you get really good at getting things
done
what tends to happen is that you get you
realize that you're getting really good
at getting the unimportant things done
and actually the important things are
being pushed back over the horizon just
as much
as ever and i think what's going on
there is just you know the more you
convince yourself
that you can do everything
the less filtering you apply when
something
comes onto your radar um the more likely
you are to say yes to anything either
internally if it's a
a ambition of your own or to a request
from someone else because you never go
through that process of like well okay
what am i going to neglect
in favor of this thing and so if you
think about it that just like over time
that just means that your list is going
to fill with more and more
things that haven't met a quality
threshold and you will in the words of
jim benson a workplace consultant who i
quote in the book become a limitless
reservoir for other people's
expectations um it's just like you'll
just end up doing what other people
would like someone else to be handling
on their behalf that's an interesting
way to look at productivity that it
actually reduces
how skeptical or how many scruples you
have around the things that you choose
to do if you can get twice as much work
done
in a given period of time
you can
get twice as much of the important stuff
done or be half as judgmental when it
comes to choosing what you want to get
done
right and i think the thing to remember
there is that like
most
possibly this is a human universal but
most people who are like sort of
have a bit of dynamism and want to do a
few things with their lives that there's
going to be
the no matter how
productive you get there's always going
to be more genuinely meaningful and
important things than the capacity will
allow so you're probably not going to
have
the bandwidth to start messing with the
things that you don't particularly care
about and there's a there's a lovely
observation from elizabeth gilbert uh
the novelist and writer on productivity
and author of pray love
uh
underrated book in some quarters i think
it's actually really good um
that uh you know we we hear all these
bromides about the importance of saying
no
and you secretly think that what that
means is you have to like
start
being willing to say no to all the crap
that people
are asking you to do that that you don't
really want to do but actually it's way
more challenging than that it's saying
no
to things that you really do want to do
and that really do matter and that it
would have been really good to spend
some time on it's not that you just get
to choose
this is like a little back door to
continuing this kind of problematic way
of behaving is like i'm going to get so
productive so that everything that
matters gets done and i'm going to
accept that i'm not going to get all the
things that don't matter done but it's
now it's way harder than that it's not
doing everything that does matter so if
time management's ultimately doomed to
fail what's novel about what you're
proposing here
i mean i don't know that it's novel if
you're going to go all the way back
through the history of philosophy um i
think you know seneca got there first
and
heidegger in a
in a sort of
slightly more
nazi way i don't really need to
uh
one of
one of them
are you saying that heidegger managed to
out-nut see you in this book i was
adamant that this was some sort of
treaties towards hitler
this is a this is a word that gets
thrown around a lot uh these days uh but
but heidegger was as absolutely
canonically a nazi as it's possible
no no no just a nazi and it's very
difficult because like actually i think
you know being in time to the extent
that i've grappled with it and tried to
understand it really gets at something
very wise about the nature of time but
then you have to issue all these caveats
because he was literally a party member
um
what's in unique about my what's what's
new about what i'm saying
i think it is
what i'm trying to convey
is this notion of a kind of surrender
that isn't disempowering
so it's this idea of like it's a kind of
acceptance
acceptance of reality that is kind of
bracing and motivating
and
focusing i guess this word acceptance
has been
it has a lot of weird connotations
either it feels like resignation
or it feels like um
uh
sort of just overly new age you know you
feel like books about acceptance are
going to have
a little tableau of
flowers on the cover or a pebble
something but
um
but there's something quite muscular
about it there's something quite i mean
cal newport um who i'm sure you'll be
you and your listeners will be familiar
with but
talks about
uh facing the productivity dragon which
is his phrase for like
not pretending that there aren't more
things
demanding your attention than there are
and facing up to it and making tough
decisions if you have to about what you
can actually do
and there's some i like that spirit i
like that sort of um
i like the idea that it's kind of
scary on a level on some way to um
to
see how things actually are with respect
to time
but the payoff for doing it is
that
you get to sort of
stop using up all your time and
attention and energy trying to do
something impossible and focus it on
doing a few things that
that are possible
so if time is limited
that means that we need to say no to
certain things
how can people think more clearly about
these sort of trade-offs
i mean there are lots of ways of
implementing this at different
levels sort of
per domain of life or per task i mean i
think one very simple one of the
productivity approaches that really does
that is consonant with all of this
is um
is anything that's that's sort of based
around the idea of doing one thing at a
time so if you can limit your work in
progress there are sort of the kanban
methodology is one way of doing this
if you can sort of pick one big goal in
each domain of your life and sort of
attempt to complete that one before
moving on to the others
it's anything that has this spirit of
like okay there's lots of things i could
be doing
but instead of giving in
to the the good feeling of like having a
finger in every pie taking care of
business touching every project in the
course of a day
and actually not
making progress on any of them um
i'm gonna sort of
tolerate that uncertainty
that that comes sorry that discomfort
that knows fraud that comes from
knowing that
important things are being neglected in
order to sort of focus on
on one thing and i think that can work
at the level of kind of big projects and
day-to-day
day-to-day tasks um
that's one i can i can talk endlessly
about ways to sort of implement this
basic single basic uh perspective shift
i like the idea of deciding what we're
gonna fail at can you dig into that
yeah this is an idea i got originally
from an author called john a cuff and he
just makes this very
kind of obvious once it's been pointed
out to you point that um
if this finite situation means that
we're going to
fail to um excel to 100
in every single domain that we can
possibly think of
which it does um
then then it makes a lot of sense to
sort of
select in
advance uh for a given time period you
know something that you're some area of
life that you're going to
uh accept your
non excelling in so
you know you might you might decide that
i mean one thing is you know i think
especially for people young people at
certain stages their careers you know
really going all in to work for on work
for a while can be a perfectly
legitimate decision
and maybe not attempting to have an
incredibly rich sort of life outside
work with
all manner of hobbies and relaxation and
uh
etc etc
or it could be something as simple as
saying like you know
i'm
i'm trying to do well in my work and
raise a small child i'm not going to be
the person who has a really tidy house
or
six pack abs
right right right or as impressive a
cook this is the thing for me it's just
like once i accept that like as long as
i'm when it i'm feeding myself and my
family basically helpfully it's like i
think i have to put on hold for several
more years from now the moment when i
can really wow people with the with the
dishes that i can that i can whip up and
yeah fitness right i don't want to tell
tell anyone they just give up on that
but there's obviously different kinds of
goals you can have between like
maintenance and reducing your risk of
heart disease through to uh
you know winning marathons and and
and being sort of incredibly
impressively muscular
so
the point being that you're going to
experience certain kinds of
uh
failure and different domains and if you
do this in advance you can really focus
your efforts
you can make no effort or relatively
speaking no effort in some other area if
you don't do that you're going to sort
of spread yourself thinly not get far
enough in each one and be constantly
disappointed that you didn't reach
uh 100
in on any given um in any given domain
yeah there's two things going on there
one of them is the uh internal
relinquishing of a sense that i should
be doing better
by accepting in advance look this is the
hill that i'm going to work on for the
next
six months or whatever or these are the
hills and i'm going to concede that
these ones aren't so i don't have this
potentiality gap between where i think i
could be and where i am because i've
already conceded right i've i've
wrangled the chaos of the next few
months into order by having a plan and
by laying it out but the other thing
which is equally important
is that you're going to be more
competitive within the domains that you
narrowly choose to try and excel in
because
you are not going to win a marathon
by being great at work and you're not
going to be getting a promotion at work
by being good at a marathon however if
you allow yourself to progress tightly
within one domain for a period of time
you can then coast in that let's say
that you do spend a good amount of time
on a training plan and you decide right
i'm going to die down and i'm going to
get myself to a good level of body fat
and i'm going to get some some muscle
and build my lifts up that strength will
carry itself on
far more effectively than if you tried
to do you can get done in six months of
focused work what would take three years
of disparately focused work and the same
thing goes for
think about a youtube thing the pareto
distribution is a hell of a drug right
like it's everywhere
and you think if you want to be in the
top five percent of anything you're
going to get disproportionate returns to
somebody that's in the top 10 or the top
20
because it it gets super competitive at
the top but the returns are also sort of
uh they become is it logarithmic is that
the one i mean not exponential the
returns become exponential towards the
top so you get far more returns than the
tiny tiny increases that you need to put
in and another thing to consider and
this is something i've been saying for
so long to myself shouting it in my own
ears but everyone else is too it's like
look
the vast majority of people cannot let
go of the tether of doing everything at
once
this means that consistency and a narrow
focus is a competitive advantage
one of the reasons that you can really
excel in your industry is because other
people aren't prepared to commit to that
industry because they have this same
compulsion that you do as well they have
social engagements and a family and they
want to spend money on a car but also a
house and they want to learn to be a
good cook but they want to have six-pack
abs and they want to
pick whatever it is everybody else has
this compulsion too
so by deciding to create some sort of
bottleneck or forcing function or
limiting choice or whatever it might be
you are selecting yourself out of that
pool of other people you are giving
yourself a competitive advantage and
existentially it's going to be less
painful because you're going right okay
i'm not going to be super fit i you know
go to the gym a couple of times a week
to just maintain for the next year or
six months or whatever
but that doesn't matter because i chose
i chose this in advance
yeah absolutely i think it's incredibly
powerful and i yeah i appreciate the way
you unpack that into the two
uh
the two different elements that are that
are going on here and i think yeah i
think it's
the reason that we don't want to do that
deep deep deep down is this notion that
if we are
working on everything
we're approaching gradually never
actually reaching the state of
controls because it takes trust right it
takes um
to put one thing on hold for a while and
believe that you're going to
get around to it in a subsequent
six-month period or something it takes a
kind of self-trust you need to know that
that when that time comes you'll you can
switch gears and and do that um and if
you come at it from a sort of control
freaky untrusting unself-trusting
position that's when you're like well i
better take care of it all right now and
i think quite a lot of the sort of the
stuff around like
morning and daily routines has been
quite
damaging for this because it's sort of
it's encouraging this notion that you've
got to sort of
find time in an hour and a half in the
morning for 12 different uh
for 12 different practices um it it
really sort of
like i don't know i think i've really
benefited from
meditating but am i finding time for it
at the moment i gotta be honest and say
no i'm doing some other things with uh
with the time i would be using for that
and like i think that's okay i think
that's i think that applies to
a million different
uh domains yeah and if you're gonna have
i know i keep mentioning this but if
you're gonna have small children they're
they're gonna be they're gonna be the
priority for a good while whether you
like it or not
i think another reason that people
like having their fingers in multiple
fires fingers and multiple pies toes in
multiple fires
is that
it creates an n of one
that gives them culpable deniability
about why they might not be performing
particularly well within a particular
industry
oh yeah so if you are the only
skateboarding cricketing bodybuilding
salesperson of insurance in the uk
that also moonlights as a chef
then
right being a bit [ __ ] at all of them
almost gets excused because it's like
yeah but no one else is doing this no
one else gets what i'm doing so there is
a little bit of a get out of jail free
card there no i think that's totally
right and i think that um
it reminds me of you know i think
especially in the world of sort of
content creation and the attention
economy more generally
we get confused don't we about what what
what constitutes the the useful and
meaningful form of extraordinary of
being extraordinary and and people sort
of there's people are incentivized to
like yeah
to do things that are
out of the ordinary or weird
combinations and and um
uh there's all sorts of stuff i've read
in the past about how the way to find a
niche in in writing or whatever it might
be
is to just
these seemingly very bizarre
sort of
combinations of weird stuff and yeah
have your finger in multiple pies
that remind relates to something else
that i write about which is that
actually like there's there's there's
real power in the willingness to invest
the time
in sticking to one
path and and sort of
go through that period of
this is the helsinki bus station theory
i can talk about it if you want but yeah
this idea of like going through the
process of unoriginality to get to the
originality on the other side that's
this idea that goes back to this finnish
american finnish american photographer
called arno minkin and
where he tells this whole story about um
how uh in helsinki all the all the buses
at the central bus station in helsinki
start from the same place
and then
uh all the routes lots of the routes
sort of overlap with each other through
the center of the city lots so the
routes are the same and it's only when
they get to the outskirts that they
start to like branch off into different
places and i think i probably won't try
and go through the whole story here but
the basic idea is
you
in lots of creative work especially you
have to stick with um
you have to stick with paths that feel
like they're what everyone else is doing
feel like
you're just uh an apprentice
feel like they're not what you're not
sort of making a name for yourself in
order to get to
the place at the end of that process
that is unique and and defines you as a
sort of unique voice so it's another
example of you know of this
extraordinary power that being able to
cultivate patients can can give you i
think in the especially in the
world we live in now
even if somebody accepts everything that
we've said as gospel to-do-list anxiety
is still going to arise
how can someone who's addicted to the
sense of feeling productive learn to let
go of that tether
i think you know two approaches that may
well
be familiar to some of your listeners
but that really work with this process
the first is anything
any form of
organizing your day that draws on the
basic principles of time boxing right
anything that takes
anything that puts time first so so
uh you you decide to work on a certain
project or or to do or to just do work
per se
for a certain number of hours
and then you stop
and then you make your choices about
what to focus on based on that
limitation you don't say i'm going to
get through all of this and if it takes
me
till midnight that's fine you say
i'm going to stop at
whatever time i'm going to work for
however long
and just like taking those time
going sort of schedule first in that way
can be very helpful i think first for
some people because it's sort of
it it's uncomfortable but it but it
delineates where the discomfort is and
then the big challenge is you have to
get up when the timer goes off or when
the moment comes you have to like pull
yourself away and not expect
to feel great about pulling yourself
away
and then just another implementation of
this that i mentioned is this idea of
keeping two to-do lists right so you
have your unlimited open to-do list that
probably has like 3 000 you know 200
things on it that you
that you need to do and then another
that is limited to say five slots
and you move tasks from the long list
to the shortlist but the rule is that
you can't
add more than five so you can't add a
new one until a slot has been freed up
by completing it that's just a one very
simple example of a self-chosen
bottleneck
that um
again you know it's not that you're
doing less it's that you always were
making those choices but now they are
conscious and so you know
then you have to decide if i can only
focus on five things right now
they better be five that are that are
worth my my time have you heard of cold
turkey the app
yes but i don't know what it does so it
is a good way to ensure that you finish
work when you say you do and cold turkey
in it has a function called frozen
turkey and frozen turkey will
lock you out of your own computer at a
preset time and there is nothing that
you can do about it so i have a couple
of i have a couple of buddies who've got
it set um
i i actually think it was part of the uh
part of a very argumentative discussion
with their partners around um you you
work too late okay well i can do this
thing that causes me to be locked out of
the laptop uh but
they've told me that
the degree of
furiousness
and anxiety during the three minutes
leading up to when that happens
is a sight to behold
because they just realize they're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] as fast as possible
trying to get everything done scheduling
stuff to be sent for 8 p.m because they
know that they're not going to be there
um
but yeah i think
it's so it's so interesting that
you know whether you be a knowledge
worker whether you be an entrepreneur or
even somebody that has a more typical
job that that does have bounded time
slots for it
we we set ourselves goals of of tasks to
be done not time blocks to be worked in
and
i mean i i do it as well i i have tasks
that this is what i'm going to do today
not this is how long i'm going to work
on things to do today
and it it's only ever going to lead in a
society where you're you're sort of
encouraged it's a meritocracy and you're
encouraged to work harder it's only ever
going to
lead to you over indulging in work
right and that's why i mean you you can
through absolutely and i've been there
and not infrequently still go there but
it's it's um
that's why i think practice with various
different time blocking approaches and
the the sort of fully featured pomodoro
technique does this too when you sort of
read the or you know go beyond just the
idea of 25 minute bursts of work um
it is a sort of training ground for
getting better at estimating
how long things are going to take you or
of sort of putting in the inevitable
extra hour like accounting for one of
your time blocked hours with all the
things that i know i don't can't predict
but i know i'm going to end up having to
that are going to overrun um so you can
get better but yeah i don't think it
ever becomes
perfect i don't think it ever goes the
anxiety ever goes away if you're
someone who's kind of
in any way trying to sort of do
interesting things in the world i mean
there may be exceptions to do with very
very scheduled and timetable based work
which can be you know
very high
status work as very as well as
low status work you know if it really is
strictly on a on a timetable but even
there i feel like you know
my go-to thought there is that like
surely this must be easier on teachers
because of the way timetables work but i
know from every teacher i know that this
is not true but think about it think
about a personal trainer think about a
personal trainer like you can't train
somebody unless they're in front of you
that you genuinely can't but i know tons
of personal trainers and because of
access to social media there's always oh
i could i could go
searching for another client because
i've got it i've got a friday 3pm slot
that needs filling so and this is the
this is the justification that we have
around social media that it always
it always can present itself
as utility deriving work
not work work distracting time wasting
yep
plus that trainer probably wants to have
a whole sort of content marketing arm to
their operations right so
there'll be limitless potential there to
write blog posts um yeah no absolutely
there's no real there's no real way
around it i don't know lighthouse
keepers maybe they maybe it works for
them to uh oh wow yeah just follow
straight
do it do the other even lighthouse
keepers today i don't know but like
there's a very limited number of jobs
that are not subject to this um
this bleed into the whole of life i
think yeah it's kind of like being an
animal carer
but it's the internet that you're
looking
after yeah yeah
which is kind of sad
think about that
think about it as well that because of
the internet you are
genuinely permitting
any person that has a smartphone
unless you've turned your notifications
off and even if you have then when you
log on and you finally do check
you're actually permitting
whatever is five billion people that
have access to the internet
every single one of them
can make a thing happen that changes the
course of your day
there is no way
that humans were psychologically
designed to be able to imbibe the entire
world news in real time 24 hours a day
yeah
totally yeah it's a it's a complete
the you know yeah i always think about
it's in the context of like
in the context of like causes that we're
supposed to care about right um
the greatest saints in history the most
compassionate people who've ever lived
with them who given the most of their
time to other people we're never asked
to care about the number of
instances of human suffering that like
just jumping onto twitter will expose
you to and in that case you therefore
need a kind of slightly almost callous
seeming approach to be like well it's
not that i'm not going to care about any
of this but i'm going to pick my
pick my issues and if i want to be an
activist in some area or give money to
some cause it's going to
like
yeah and that phrase um if you're not
outraged you're not paying attention
which always seems like it's so
anachronistic now it's like no no we're
all paying attention to everything and
permanently outraged about everything
actually the only way to really
efficiently care about
something in your life and i think this
probably applies
to everything in life is is to
is to be okay with not not caring about
but not caring about other things yeah
what's the danger of seeing leisure as
an area for self-improvement
well i think that's kind of like it's
almost the
it's the epitome of where all this
ridiculousness is leading right that
that like not only would you um
be kind of sort of on this productivity
treadmill
in a counterproductive fashion
in your work but that it then comes to
colonize your your um
your your time off and and this is this
you know
so that
sometimes you get it people talk about
it literally as in this idea that you
should use your time off
to become a better
worker
um
but other times it's just a it's just
subtle thing right it's this idea that
like you're not really using your
leisure time well unless you're training
for some event or you're improving a
skill
or you're
doing some
like
program of reading certain kinds of
fiction to get through a certain list of
them or whatever it might be it actually
you know this this focus on the future
at the total expense of the present it's
a problem in all aspects of life but
it's it's particularly obviously
um self-defeating when it's when it's
leisure that we're talking about here
because
um
yeah i mean
it means fundamentally means that
leisure becomes another kind of another
kind of work um
uh it actually gets really hard i mean
like this is my personal experience
anyway
it's not that
it's not that you don't get the
opportunity to rest it's that you do get
the opportunity to rest and then you
kind of don't want to do it when uh
when the opportunity arises dig into
that relationship between the present
and the future for me
well this is instrumentalization right i
mean this is just the idea that on some
level
we all have to treat time as something
we're using now
for a future
uh purpose or benefit and that's not
like you can't
you can't give that up because then you
sort of can't do anything um i wouldn't
got this book written
um you wouldn't record these uh podcasts
if you were only living for the value of
the moment itself you're we're always
doing these things
but i think all sorts of um pressures in
the modern world and modern economy push
us to completely over invest in in that
perspective right so you're you're
constantly
uh valuing
every moment in time exclusively for
that future
benefit and the problem there is pretty
obvious like you place all
the value of anything you do at a time
that's always in the future you're never
really
fully present for life which is another
thing that there's a great alan watts
quote about that i can't remember in
detail right now but so
it's really sneaky because of course it
feels very dutiful it feels like you're
being a good person and doing what you
ought to be doing in life uh when you're
doing this it doesn't feel like you're
being a time waster or sort of addicted
to social media or something it feels
like you're doing what you ought to be
doing and yeah it's um the result
is is that you're never present for your
own life
isn't there a quote something to do with
cats and
and kittens or something
oh yeah this is um john maynard keynes
talking about the the purpose of man uh
this idea of like the perp the person
who lives entirely for
for the purposes that he's putting his
time to um
yeah and no doesn't doesn't really love
his cat but only the cat's kittens and
not really the cat's kittens but really
the kittens kittens and so on forward to
the end of captain
um
yeah i mean that puts it that puts it
very nicely right it's like it takes
away from the present to invest
everything that you care about in some
future point because the future just uh
future just keeps on coming and you
never get there one of my favorite sam
harris quotes i want to give this to you
and
get your thoughts on it as a matter of
conscious experience the reality of your
life is always now and i think that this
is a liberating truth about the nature
of the human mind in fact i think
there's probably nothing more important
to understand about your mind than that
if you want to be happy in this world
the past is a memory it's a thought
arising in the present the future is
merely anticipated it is another thought
arising now what we truly have is this
moment and this
and we spend most of our lives
forgetting this truth refuting it
fleeing it overlooking it
and the horror is that we succeed
we manage to never really connect with
the present moment and find fulfillment
there because we are continually hoping
to become happy in the future
and the future never arrives
even when we think we're in the present
moment
we're in very subtle ways always looking
over at shoulder anticipating what's
coming next we're always solving a
problem and it's possible to simply drop
your problem problem if only for a
moment and enjoy whatever is true of
your life in the present
that's great
yeah yeah
what do you want me to say i mean i i
agree completely i think um the part
that really interests me is towards the
end there
the the sort of subtle ways in which
uh trying to be present in the moment is
another example of
not really appreciating that it's only
always now
um
again because it implies that it might
be possible to be separate from the
moment and and therefore like to sort of
succeed or fail at
being present in it which
which clearly makes no sense i mean i
think the
the
the sort of this is a very
there's some aspects of this that like i
have understood in the middle of a
meditation retreat but then you lose the
moment you're trying to like you know
actually live
the rest your life the way the sort of
narrow keyhole
between those two
domains that has always helped me
is
is to understand that
you know
anxious thoughts about what the future
holds are also an example of something
that you're
experiencing in the moment
plans that you have for your
day that feel very very important are
also
thoughts arising in the present moment
and it's not that you know it's a gross
sort of
occasionally you get it kind of crude
you can counter the sort of crude
misinterpretation of these ideas that
that we should be stopping or such
thinking and and that you should only be
feeling the physical sensations and
perceptual
input of being where you are
you know actually of course making plans
is really useful and to a certain extent
anxiety can can have a sort of
motivating role if you keep it in check
but understanding or being able to step
back again and remember that that is all
unfolding now is is very powerful now i
won't pretend to have reached a level of
spiritual enlightenment maybe i don't
know if sam harris would
where i can
sort of get the most value out of those
thoughts
while in that same exact moment knowing
that they are nothing but thoughts
arising in the moment like i think when
i get lost in thought because i'm
writing something and i want it to be
good
like
i am living in the i am not living fully
in the moment in those those times or
maybe i am maybe that's flow but maybe
that's a bad example but you know what i
mean it's like that when i'm planning my
day because i need it to go a certain
way
it's useful to step back and remember
that this is just a plan in the present
i'm not sure i'm really thinking that in
the very moment of planning that that
seems like it would require a power of
presence that i'm maybe still working
towards there's a quote in the book that
says what we forget is a plan is just a
thought right
right that's joseph goldstein um
the meditation teacher and i think it's
it's such a great if you get it i'm not
sure one automatically gets it from the
how do you get words but i'm sure you
sorry how do you get it what do you say
how do you well i don't know i do and i
think you do so i'm just saying like if
this this quote lands in somebody's mind
is listening and they don't say what's
the fuss about there
it's
it's a little hard to
to say i think but but to me that is
just like
i think we sort of naturally think of
plans as kind of
um
hooks we're trying to throw over the
future to bring it under our control and
that quote for me anyway serves as a
reminder that a plan is just like any
other thought that you're having in the
present moment like the thought that
you're hungry or the thought that you
wish you hadn't said that embarrassing
thing to that person um
the thought that
your intention for your day is that it
unfold in a certain way is similarly
just a present moment statement of
intent and i think it can be useful and
it can be great to write it down so that
you can refer to it when you face
decision points in the day
but if you think it's more than that
if you think that it's going to somehow
lever you into a
position over time
such that
you're in control uh and time isn't um
then you're just going to be constantly
running up against reality in a in a
painful and stress-inducing way
yeah i think that
the challenge that people have
that comes right back to what you said
at the beginning
is that there is a denial of death here
that there is a
a fear of being a finite creature
surrounded by infinite complexity and
that the more that i can wrangle that
chaos into order through plans through a
productivity system
maybe just maybe i can get more life in
or maybe i can protect myself from the
chaos that's occurring around me
and if that is the case
then
maybe i can almost transcend death i do
think it's very much a rehabilitated
eternalistic thinking you know yeah
far fewer people now are believing that
we're going to rise up to heaven or fall
down to hell
so
how can i assuage this denial of death
like you know would ernest becker be a
productivity guru in 2021
yeah it's a it's a quest for exemption
somehow isn't it from from the situation
that we're all that we're all in and you
know i yeah absolutely i'm it's it's um
i feel it in myself right i mean uh
i don't need to go into the details here
but right now i'm
wrangling some situation involving an
application for a passport and um
it's it's extremely intoxicating that
notion that if that if certain things
could just be
confirmed and fixed and known
then
it wouldn't just be that this one
particular issue could be disregarded it
would be that one had reached uh uh
one was back in a situation of sort of
not being vulnerable to unfolding events
it's the level of the computer game
where you no longer have any problems
right but of course
if i sorted out this burdensome passport
thing and stepped out into the street
there is no guarantee that a grand piano
won't fall on my head from a
from an apartment higher up right i mean
and that's obviously a little bit absurd
but but something else could happen and
indeed something else will happen so
what are some good questions that people
can ask themselves to help refine their
direction for this
well i love and always talk about this
question that comes from james hollis
the the jungian analyst and writer which
is to ask of every big life question
that you're approach that you're um
encountering whether it will enlarge you
or diminish you um it can sound a bit
kooky at first but this is as an
alternative to like will this job make
me happy will this relationship make me
happy would i be happier if i left this
relationship or did this other thing
this question of enlargement
and diminishment
seems to connect something intuitive
that i think most people already know
about a path
that they're on they know whether
they know whether the
the stresses and difficulties that they
encounter in say a relationship are the
kind of stresses and difficulties that
are making them a bigger person and
are worth sticking with for the payoff
uh and a sort of part of growth
or whether they're the kind that sort of
make your soul shrivel up and it's clear
that like you two are just completely
incompatible and should go your separate
ways and i think that applies to all
sorts of other domains as well so that i
think
is one of the
questions that i
uh like to bang on about um
another one
just to mention is
this whole idea that i think we put off
doing a lot of um
worthwhile and important things
uh pending sometime when we're gonna
feel sort of fully qualified to do them
and i think even people who aren't um
uh burdened by imposter syndrome in that
sort of direct sense of thinking that
they are a fraud they're still very very
easy i think especially in younger
adulthood to be like oh well you know
i'm not going to launch this project now
or do this thing now because clearly
what i'm going to do is i'm going to in
five years time i'm going to really know
what i'm doing
and
in the sense in which that is meant i
don't think anyone ever knows what
they're doing and they're all completely
winging it all the time and the only
reason you don't hear there in the
monologues of
self-doubt
is because you're not inside their heads
um
and it differs you know some people
probably are too bold in launching
things that they should that they should
do more preparation for but i think the
overwhelming
bias that we have is towards holding
back
uh pending the time when we feel like we
know what we're doing and it might be
worth
contemplating the possibility that
nobody ever knows nobody ever feels like
they know what they're doing
i've got some buddies who
have risen up through the ranks of
financial institutions
and they were talking about this sort of
red pilling of their imposter syndrome
because they presumed that you know when
you get into the real big board rooms
you know when you're on the
the 35th floor and it's float to ceiling
glass and everybody in there's on a
million a year
that finally finally people will know
what they're doing and they came out and
they said it's literally morons all the
way up
[Laughter]
yeah yeah well i guess that's the yeah
that's the disdainful way to put it the
other way to think about it is of course
that we're all morons in some in some
important sense which means like yeah
you have as much chance of
pulling off whatever you're trying to
pull off as as anybody else yeah
and obviously the
seriousness of
your book's title
4 000
weeks
the reason for that is that that's the
length of time of somebody that lives
ish
lives for
80 years and there's a quote that you
open the book with from douglas harding
it's the very last thing isn't it we
feel grateful for having happened you
know
you needn't have happened you needn't
have happened but you did happen
and the
infinitesimal
tiny tiny tiny fraction of a chance
that you are alive for this moment for
these four thousand weeks
that is reason
to place a very very high
value on your time to ensure that the
things that you are doing genuinely do
matter to you not just now but that
you're going to look back in
10 years 50 years time and say that is
how i wanted to spend my time that's the
degree of perspective that we that we
should be taking care of the moment
it is
it is the only thing i want to say to
sort of develop that is
i wouldn't want people to go away from
this with the idea that
what that means is this kind of white
knuckle attempt to seize the day
in a kind of stressful
like gotta pack every day with the most
amazing experiences
i can find and like spend every weekend
base jumping whatever you know i it's
not
it's almost like i i hope that it i hope
that i can get this perspective where
yes the stakes are incredibly high
because the chances of you being born
or infinitesimal the amount of time you
have
is not at all long
but there's also something very i think
relaxing and liberating and empowering
about seeing that you know precisely
because that is the situation
um
the attempt to sort of outrun these
limitations
uh and and do more than any human could
do and live longer than any human could
live like you get to drop that because
you already got the gift which is like
some time on the planet so
one way i want to phrase it maybe it's
not like you must do things with your
life that matter to you but that like
you might as well
spend your time doing things that matter
to you like
what have you got to lose
uh compared to someone who never got to
be born so
there's something about this that i hope
that i find relaxing and i hope
other people do as well not
not
numbing not not like so spend the rest
of your life on a hammock
on a beach but
but relaxing in the sense that the
pressure is off and it's because the
pressure is off that you might as well
spend your life doing
things that really really matter to you
oliver berkman ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out more of your
stuff where should they go
well the book uh four thousand weeks uh
that's uh
there then go to uh 4000 weeks book.com
400 weeksbook.com which is really just a
page on my website which is
oliverbirkman.com
i love it cheers oliver
thank you very very much
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace